Hãy chừng ngà sẽ kê là VROP người Mỹ bà tháng 18,
tổng thống Mỹ đường đần trăm đánh nhận đường một số báo cáo bị mặt.
Chứ của gặp sự kiến với tổng thống ngà là đi Mỹ của chiến tại Budapest giãn tơi viện của gặp bị huy.
Ông là VROP nói không gióng một gác của các báo cá hậu chương,
nhưng sau khi xem xét, tổng thống đường đần trăm đã quy định huy hội nghị thương đình.
Ngà báo bỏ cám một chứ sẵn sàng đảm phán, khẳng đình vẫn sẵn sàng tổ chứ đường đình nếu dự trên các thích qua đã đề được tại Alaskar,
nơi hay bên từng thảo luận xa y phép, cho vẫn đều khuyên à.
Theo ngoại trường Lavro, Más các bạn có những thật thận này là thương sử, cho tính chình hoa đình.
Vô ở với đệ xuất của tổng thống của chiến đường xa từ tháng sáo nâng những không trà mi tư.
Ông cũng chào biết, chính quyền Mỹ thường nhận việc đường khuyên à bỏ nátor là không thể chấm nhận và không thể bỏ qua
các cuộc chương câu ít sân ở những vùng đã sắp nhật vào ngà.
Sok y của gặp bị huy, phía ngà cho sàng, hoa xinh tình cần xem xét ký lượng hơn,
các yếu tổ hội quán chức yếu giác quy định mới.